this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
welcome to engineering and climate
change this is a very special week we've
got a guest lecturer Doug stop with us
who you will find amazing again the
purpose of the class is trying to give
you the tools to go out there and make a
difference and here is the graphic of
what we're covering this quarter so
where are we so we've covered a number
of really important lectures about how
while an introduction to yes there is
climate change and what's what's the
status there and a nice video visit from
terry route professor terry route then
we've had Rex telling us about how do
you on earth you find fund and foster
the most promising ideas in cleantech
kimberly we fleeing helped us figure out
how to tackle impossible problems and
find out maybe they're just really hard
for some reason i want to double check
my mic yep don fold an hour told us a
real insider's view about the solar
industry and some of the issues that
we're running into with that Doug will
give us a wonderful lecture and slide
show and and who knows what but a lot of
inspiration about firsthand observations
of climate change in polar regions that
you will find this exciting professor
will chew it is coming next week to talk
about energy storage techniques
electrochemistry and energy storage I
think this is a really remarkably
important thing when you're looking at
alternative energy and I i put in a sort
of blue darker blue this last lecture
when i'll be talking again i could tell
i sewed a little bit of confusion by
having the soft you engineering paper on
the course work site for you thinking so
is doug talking about geoengineering
know what i wanted to do was to let you
know kind of early on and this was the
right time why do I think ice is so
darned important to what's happening in
climate change and Doug knows doug has
been there important than anyone else i
think so that's that's so all your
geoengineering question
that you submitted I'm probably the
right one to be answering those in that
lecture or you know along along the way
and the rest of the quarter next week
we've got professor will chua he's in
material science and engineering and
they look at efficient electoral
chemical routes for getting solar energy
to chemical fuels which is really pretty
interesting he's one of Technology
reviews top 35 under 35 so really quite
an innovator and to celebrate that I'll
show you the readings in another slide
let's just go to that right now go to
the G sub site and i will be posting
these slides later this afternoon to our
site in the material section so you'll
be able to see these links of how you
can get read at least one paper on
advanced materials and catalysts i
actually was meeting with professor Tom
jaramillo this morning who is another
one of the chemical engineering
professors looking at electric chemical
routes to energy storage really exciting
stuff and watch the G cept site if you
have time I won't even try to pronounce
his name it's not the way it's spelled
but the video on battery storage 101
this is this is one of the real rising
stars as well and then you will have
heard in a way from all three of the top
energy storage guys here at Stanford as
far as I can tell ha Romeo's work is
here in the advanced materials in
catalyst thing we've got will true a
coming in person and then there's this
beautiful video from the G sub site so
please use the course work site for your
homework please we've decided to start
the lecture somewhere between 12 50 and
12 55 so to try to get here at 1250 if
you can if you've missed any first
minutes go ahead and look at the lecture
on the SCPD site later and you can catch
those first couple minutes again there
was a glitch please don't stress I've
had enough stress for all of us over
this there's something about the way I
have interacted with the coursework site
in which a couple of your listings of
questions for past lecturers
have been clobbered and I've talked to
the people who run that site there's no
way to recover there's no backup
fortunately I got all that captured
fortunately also I believe if I air you
don't pay so everybody gets marked off
for those two weeks where those have
disappeared 11 heads up student wrote to
me last night or this morning see where
I it's saying I didn't don't worry so
and I'm now keeping a second backup of
everything on my own there's something
dreadful that happened there so I've got
to back up to so that's the dark side of
course works but when it's working well
it's so much easier for me so please
submit your assignments there if you're
having trouble with the assignment
finding it it's under the assignments
tab and so materials is where you're
finding all our readings and such and
unless I'm referring you to external
links like the GCF but the assignments
go in the assignments tab and then look
for the title of that question and then
you should be able to just get in there
and fill your stuff out and if if that
doesn't work just email me but it's
easier for me if most of you are using
the course works um you can see how to
get the videos of the class and meeting
before lunch meeting before class over
lunch works for me we're doing it and in
Packard at bites it's a little bit
easier than here in hwange the homework
so summarize the lecture do some reading
for the next lecture email me at least
one burning question those are the
homework again there's some optional
things we can talk about optional
readings listed here somebody has
already suggested a lecturer which I
really love thank you and some readings
please do we'll talk more about that
next week we want to make room for Doug
as soon as we can this is review
information and opportunities at
Stanford nearby to learn more about
climate change and what's going on
around here I wanted to say just a
couple words about the ice albedo
feedback effect just so this comes from
my own ice 911 that you've got now your
thrilling preview of from reading that
paper basically polar ice melt is in
positive feedback and a positive
feedback
loop generally gets engineers attention
right so the more the ice melts the more
areas exposed that will absorb radiation
really well which is open ocean instead
of having areas that have what's called
a high albedo where it gets to reflect
most of the incoming radiation and so it
accelerates and ten percent of the
world's ocean area is in the Arctic in
the Antarctic so that's a big deal and
it's a big lever on climate change there
are many effects that stem from this and
climate experts estimate that this one
effect is increasing global warming by
twenty percent just itself so it's it's
a huge thing and I won't be getting to
my solution here right now with what
I've been working on trying to see if
that's a backup option but if all else
fails you do find people contemplating
various geoengineering options over time
this chart is really interesting and
it's from the two thousand or so
scientists in the IPCC the subgroup that
looked at ice melt I think I've alluded
to this before but this is quite a
remarkable slide this shows the change
in slope really well these were the
consensus of the IPCC a huge error range
of what the predictions were read being
kind of what's the middle ground here
but in 2007 far worse than that that's
when we began to really fall off the
cliff and it's even worse this year it's
making a lot of news and if you talk to
long-term ice experts who study this
they will tell you the slope is changing
over time and we're getting to see that
so that's that's a big deal it affects
it affects Antarctica it affects the
Arctic although in different ways and it
affects the Greenland it affects the
glaciers so it's a it's a big deal with
a lot of ramifications and that's why
that's why I promote books like this if
you want to learn more about ice Peter
bottoms ice in the ocean so on to this
week's lecturer who knows a lot about
ice Doug I'm not even sure what all I
can say except that you are an
extraordinary
person doing extraordinary things and
doug has as one of his real passions is
educating people sharing with them what
he knows so Arctic and Antarctic
Explorer environmentalist firsthand
observer placing experiments for
scientists as he mentioned before he
gets standing ovations when he brings
back up the observations from these
really difficult places and it's best to
let Doug tell the rest of the story so
thank you this oversee I'll just take it
away yeah so first of all thank you
Leslie fields dr. Fields for having me
come and thank you for for having me
here I know that some of you have sent
some questions and I will hopefully
answer those during my lecture and I
appreciate all the questions have been
great I really appreciate you taking the
time to send me the questions I didn't
answer them directly but hopefully I'll
answer them during my lecture if not
please ask me after that when we're done
and i'll try to answer them the best I
know how Thank You Satish and his
students for coming and joining and Mike
and Chelsea and for coming as well like
like Leslie said I am a polar adventure
I don't like to put myself in the same
category as as the turn of the century
explorers I have a satphone and modern
technology and a GPS and all the things
that that allow me to go travel to these
environments and travel safely those
guys 100 years ago did it without with a
sextant in a reindeer sleeping bag and
and once they got there they had to turn
around and go back so I call myself a
modern-day adventure I've been all over
the world as I'm seeing the planet it's
amazing it's from spitsbergen to
Greenland to the north and south pole to
the Himalaya I live up in Tahoe skiing
as a big part of my life I ski almost
every day I be skiing right now if I was
up there now I think they got about
three feet of snow so anyway it's it's a
big part of my life I've ski Antarctic I
run
hips down there on big cruise ships as
well as sailboats I'm still a dreamer I
still want to to actually do a trip
across Antarctica where I'm going to
sail from Ushuaia all the way to the
Antarctic continent I want to use kites
and kite sail all the way across the
continent and then sail all the way to
New Zealand over 4,000 miles and what I
want to do is I want to do it without
any use of any stove I want to do a
zero-carbon footprint expedition I want
to use solar panels to melt my snow use
wind power to propel myself with this
with a sailboat and with kites to be
able to go across Antarctica and be able
to do it with manpower to so if I can do
it in one of the most inhospitable
places on the planet you can certainly
do it at home I was a snowboarder at one
time you can see this is anybody ever
see Paramount Pictures it's their logo
it's a place called artisan rahu it's in
Peru and it's a beautiful peak I end up
doing the first snowboard descent of
that mountain and you could see I got a
rope attached to me at my left hand is
an ice axe I use that as a tool and
that's the name of my company ice axe
and we use it not only to climb up but
also to descend if I slipped and fell
lost an edge with my snowboard I'm able
to self arrest hopefully in a 50-degree
slope and we actually that rope is
attached to another skier and then I'll
ski the length of the rope and that's
set an anchor and then he'll ski down
but that was a 7,000 foot face that we
were able to snowboard down and skiing
in Spitsbergen finding great snow and
going places I sort of like the Sun so I
go places where there's 24 hours of Sun
quite a bit I climbed the sixth highest
peak in the world called Choi you and
this place is truly amazing it's a an
8,000 meter peak there's 14 8,000 meter
peaks in the Himalaya and this was one
of them and I did the first snowboard is
sent off this mountain amazing to be
able to go there and be able to see the
indigenous tribes and be able to
interact with the people I've also done
another couple other humanitarian
efforts in the in the Khumbu Icefall
which is also Nepal i did with dr.
dr. Bauer's and another Indian doctor we
were able to go to the the Coombe blue
ice fall and actually do cataract
Himalayan cataract project where we did
two thousand I just sort of prep the the
patients but he was able to actually do
cataract surgery on 2,000 people in two
weeks we're doing two hundred operations
a day which I'm pretty proud of that you
know this is something that a lot of fun
for me to go and do and be able to be a
part of and and these people hadn't seen
for 20 years and all sudden they can see
they thought we were gods the himalaya
is also another big place on the way up
to Everest you see this mountain called
ama dablam and i did a new route on ama
dablam up the north west ridge you can
see and actually you can see everest
from the top that's Everest but as I'm
traveling to some of these mountains I'm
seeing less glaciers the glaciers are
assessing and I'm seeing stuff in
Greenland and also over in Europe and
some of the glaciers there too so this
is what's got me to my point today is is
really all this climate change that I'm
seeing firsthand makes me want to try to
do something about it I did the first
ice bike expedition in antarctica I was
there for three weeks I designed this
bike Time magazine said it was one of
the top 30 inventions of 2004 all I did
was try to fight build a bike that I
could travel across Antarctica and I ran
about three pounds of pressure in the
tires and I hauled the sled
unfortunately due to climate change or
there was an atypical storm that came
off the weddell sea and grounded me for
five days I had 150 mile an hour winds I
was by myself in a tent I had to sort of
put my feet up against the tent so the
tent didn't collapse and keep me in it
so after five days the winds dissipated
and I was able to continue the
expedition originally I was going to do
330 miles around the Heritage range in
Antarctica I end up doing about 220 and
I do think it would be a valuable way to
cross Antarctica at a faster rate than
skiing on the cameraman Here I am in the
island of South Georgia a gentleman
mentioned earnest shock
Elton earlier i'll go into him a little
bit he's one of my heroes this is where
he was buried and also he ended up
having to do a crossing of that and I'll
tell that story real quick but my first
trip to Antarctica was in 1999 and I
went there to climb and ski and
snowboard the highest peak in Antarctica
it's the Vinson Massif it's 16,000 77
feet I was blown away our plane landed
on this ice runway I get out of the
plane it's blowing about 40 knots
there's sparkles in the air and then we
walk about a hundred meters and there's
a tent city going on and they're making
crepes and strawberries and I'm like
where am I so had a great trip with a
couple friends and just amazing amazing
time six months later I actually guided
a blind guy on a deaf guy across
Antarctica actually a blind guy and his
site guide who was deaf so that was what
probably one of the biggest challenges
in my life was over seven hundred and
forty eight miles 62 days wearing the
same underwear so it was I had all kinds
of things that I learned I end up
breaking my tooth on a piece of
chocolate and pulling it out with a
needle nose pliers I end up getting some
frostbite on a tow it was one thing
after never you end up having to have
like a repair kit as well as a medical
kit the repair kit because you're
breaking everything everything breaks at
minus 50 so nothing works so you have
extensive repairs going on all the time
and here's miles in John Cook and after
62 days 748 miles we were successful
with the journey and it was just amazing
trip and just gives you a little bit of
shows you Antarctica and during this
Ross Sea area that's usually all ice
I'll see ice and that'll stacy is all
summer long also the roni ice shelf
that's Burton or Ireland but that's all
usually sea ice a lot of the problem
that we're seeing is on this this
eastern side of the peninsula there's
about seven glaciers that are calving at
an alarming rate the Larsen B the
wilkinson blow and there's a few other
ones that are calving too
is this cyclical I'm not sure there's
huge tabular icebergs that are just
calving off I think that actually
Antarctica it's actually growing about a
foot a year there's about a foot of
accumulation in the interior of and hard
in the interior of Antarctica that's
growing there is and I spend a lot of
time on the peninsula I travel over here
from Ushuaia and I'll sail down here
almost every year and do some skiing on
this western side of the peninsula there
is noticeable differences in the
temperature and dr. Fields mentioned
that earlier how this water temperature
has as is changing and creating more ice
melt I'm seeing differences in the krill
populations which is really the little
tiny shrimps that the whole ecosystem is
relying relying on all that all the sea
life all the bird life eats that krill
so this is the observations that I'm
making with that but I think in two
thousand well do some skiing down the
pencil so I run trips here in 2007 we
mentioned ernest shackleton i wanted to
actually fly in all the way to the
filter your ice shelf and 2000 in 1914
ernest shackleton tried to do the last
great adventure which he was going to
cross the entire continent and then all
the way down to the Russ Rossi instead
in that he got in the Roni Ice Shelf the
boat got crushed he stayed on the boat
or next to the boat for almost four
months in the ice the boat end up
sinking the very last minute they made a
last-ditch effort to get to this
elephant island left 22 men there he had
one of these little tiny row boats
called the James Caird he modified it
and put some wood over it he ended up
sailing all the way to the island to
South Georgia 800 miles he got to the
wrong side he had to cross the island he
went to the wrong whaling station he had
to climb back up and from King Haakon
Bay two stromness and then he got out
stromness and went to fortuna or
actually was the other way around he got
the fortuna and then he ended up getting
the stromness he ended up sailing back
to to punta arenas chile 1,700 miles
writing a letter to the Queen of England
that took six months six months for the
money to get back because he was like
saying hey my guys are stuck in
Antarctica
and then he ended up getting the money
from the Queen and he went to go sail
before winter set out and he rescued
every one of those men so actually there
was a that boat that he got the money he
ended up sailing down and got the boat
got crushed off a cape horn and he went
back and got a year gray and navy boat
to be able to to go and actually rescue
as men and they lived on penguin and
seal for 22 months even to this day I
think you should read endurance by
alfred lansing amazing amazing story so
what I wanted to do this is just
snowboarding in Antarctica just a couple
pictures of some of the icebergs that is
a big huge tabular iceberg beautiful
icebergs everywhere lots of wildlife
down there in the peninsula leopard
seals humpback whales gentoo penguins
these penguins haven't lost all the
feathers yet elephant seals big huge cow
there's sort of interesting animals they
usually have a harem of about thirty
girlfriends another one will come up on
the beach and then they'll end up
fighting till one wins and then he'll
either take over the one that actually
was there but here's a picture of
Shackleton 1914 through 1916 in 1909 he
got within he got within ninety seven
miles of the South Pole and had the
ability to say hey we're not going to
make it I don't want to lose my man and
he came all the way back and he was with
robert falcon scott 1911 or 1912 robert
falcon scott january 17th arrived at the
geographic South Pole unfortunately it
was a month late Amundson a Norwegian
this is a British guy Amundson and
Norwegian arrived at the geographic
South Pole December 14 1911 so one month
later January 17th 1912 he arrived and
he ended up perishing on his way back
which is a really sad story I was there
twice this this past year I was there on
the anniversaries of Amundson and also
on the anniversary of Scott but we get
into Antarctica with big huge plane
Aleutian 76 aircraft amazing plane and
then we use ski equipped aircraft to get
to our destinations all the scientists
come in and so I started this
journey in 2007 where I went from the
coast that filter ice shelf and I wanted
to recreate the journey that Shackleton
intended to do it had never been done
before I used I went to a couple
glaciologist and who had done some
research back in the 50s over at the
Cambridge Scott polar Institute and I
talked to them and say well what did you
see and there was really not really any
mapping or anything so I ran into the
recovery glacier which was about 10 days
of just utter chaotic ice mess I mean
usually when you see a glacier there's
there's uniformity within the glacier
and you can see the the curve ah seng
and there was no uniformity the ice was
moving in all different directions this
is not a mountain behind this is like
upheaval of ice you can actually see our
tracks as we came across here and then
came back around and then I went set up
the camera and then I walk back and got
in the picture so it was a little bit of
work to be able to do it but a lot of
work our sleds weighed 300 pounds we
were doing unsupported trip you can see
that i started it at the coast which is
sea level and as you get up to the polar
plateau the polar plateau is 9,000 feet
3,000 meters and you can see how the the
ground undulates and I was so focused
that i found a 40-pound meteorite that
probably was worth 15 20 million dollars
and you're so focused that you don't
want to put a 40-pound meteorite in your
sled and take it home not that I'll be
able to take it with me anyway or donate
it to science so I just sort of took a
picture took some GPS coordinate and you
know I have that and but it's just
you're so focused to just keep on going
the last thing you want to do is is put
anything in your sled you just want to
take things out so because every day you
want to get lighter and lighter total
whiteout conditions you can see I'd
navigate on a lot of different ways
compass gps but on my pole you can see
there's a little flag I use a compass
and I actually able to navigate because
that's one of my biggest fears is
actually having you know losing my
friends you know and it could happen
very easily you get a little distance
between it also in the wind scours the
ski tracks away it can happen like that
and then you don't know where anybody is
but navigating
this is inside the tent I've been
pioneering technology for over 10 years
I use a little sort of like a smartphone
you're radiant satellite phone and then
you can see I have tape on my nose it's
more preventative when I sweat a lot of
the times the goggles will freeze to my
face and when I pull the goggles off
I'll rip off skin off my face so I just
put a little tape there to make sure
that doesn't happen well minus 20 quick
picture without him a shirt even myself
makes mistakes tons and tons of
experience but 2007 i ended up 2008 i
ended up taking my goggles off they
froze solid i couldnt navigate i
couldn't see anything i lifted him off i
went without goggles for about about 3
hours and i got snow blonde and for
three days i ended up just so painful
just taking painkillers just trying to
get through to get to the South Pole and
finally we were successful to get to the
geographic South Pole and it took about
five days for my site to get back
there's the there's they have a scepter
at the pole they change every year
there's a new scepter that's placed
there I've seen a bunch of them i bin I
can actually go back to 2000 where I
there my original time that I arrived at
the South Pole and see where that was
and it's moved moves about about 30 feet
every year give or take five or ten feet
sometimes more sometimes less and it's
not so much the pole is moving but the
whole ice sheets movie and there's a big
base there the base is awesome 443
million-dollar base we're not allowed to
go into it we're considered tourists so
they are doing some great science I
scores at in the wintertime or in their
winter which is basically our summer
they got telescopes they're able to find
new 860 million years ago new galaxies
every day there's no water vapor in the
air so it's super high up so they're
able to see all kinds of really cool
stuff but you can see my tent I'm camped
right next to the base and I'm fine with
that I weighed 217 pounds at the start
of that journey it was 47 day trip and
at the end i weighed 173 so you've heard
of the south beach diet this is the
South Pole diet
and I had to shave my head and you can
see I got a little bit of a patch still
going on from my snowboard brings me to
2005 I've put together an international
North Pole trip with two other friends
of mine Norwegian and a dutch guy and I
didn't want to just go to the North Pole
I wanted to try to make a difference so
I went to the scientists I said how can
I help they handed me a 50-pound beacon
and they said we want you to take ten of
these and I said well I can't even take
one of these because I can't I don't
want to carry 50 pounds with me so i
ended up redesigning the beacon and they
weigh about seven kilos and with carbon
fiber tubing and the instruments are
temperature gauge barometric pressure
gauge and a GPS as well as your written
modem that pings up data to a satellite
and down to the outfit Vanga Institute
in Germany and this is something I'm
really proud of and also the Arctic buoy
program which is about 16 different
nations as using this beacon that I've
designed to now so it's you never know
what's going to happen this trip started
up and I flew into tomas co then flew it
to cross nias scanned then all the way
to Siberia to this place called ha Tonka
where it was a amazing place there's a
there's dog and Indians there was sort
of this old military town underneath
like there's all these like missile silo
things underneath the underneath the
town i ran into these dog and Indians
these plate these guys are really really
cool they travel by reindeer and they're
cruising across the tundra and there
what's happening is that the permafrost
is melting and a lot of these woolly
mammoth tusks are starting to appear and
this was one really interesting I was
standing here right after I took this
picture there was a Japanese guy that
walked up here and had a hair dryer and
he's blowing this big ice chunk you can
see this this is under underneath the
the town there's like these caverns
where they probably had missiles going
and then the the earth would open up and
they'd point it toward probably Alaska
because we're that close that's the
proximity but he took a hair dryer and
he started blow drying some of this this
is a whole mammoth carcass
and he started pulling live hair or not
live but frozen hair and flesh out of
this carcass and he wanted to artificial
inseminating the DNA into a modern-day
elephant I'm not all for this kind of
thing because I don't know that why did
they become extinct anyway is there
going to be some plague that's going to
come out come back or whatever but uh
certainly interesting there they've
actually plays 360 thousand acres up
there's a class this is this is ten
thousand and thirty thousand year old
plasticine era so this is um they made a
plasticine park you've heard a Jurassic
Park but this is a plasticine park where
they've actually introduced musk ox and
they're studying them and they're going
to try to do these elephants hybrids but
this is inside the saying all kinds of
tusks you can see how I see the inside
it was super cold in there five hours a
day light I'd love to go travel with
these Dolgan Indians just to check out
you know see that see the effects that's
happening with them with the permafrost
they're saying they're having all kinds
of trouble because it's getting soggy
and they're not able to travel in the
summer months when it used to be just
all ice and snow to be able to travel
across this is an interesting photo this
was a actually februari 29th and that
just shows you the North Pole this is
Greenland this is North America or
Canada actually Alaska the Bering
Straits all of Siberia I was leaving
from this point right here called k
parcha cesky i leave from a lot of my
trips from a place here called
spitsbergen and that's part of europe
really and but I was leaving from this
point and that yellow means the the
purple is all ice the yellow portion is
all open water and that was the day I
was supposed to leave here's a close-up
picture of this and it shows this is Kay
party cesky so this is a februari 21st i
left march one so I waited about another
week ten days because I was leaving from
this point here and this is all open
water which is scary you can't even
leave from this point anymore we were
the last team to leave and that was in
2005 to actually make an attempt from
from Russia
and we ended up starting March one and
we got to about maybe 120 miles we are
trying to move as fast as we could but
for the first two days I couldn't find
any place to camp so what I was doing is
um we just kept on moving and it was
super dark the light the eternal son
doesn't come out until March 22nd so we
had 22 days and it was every every day
you get probably about another 40
minutes of light but it started about 40
be like five hours of light on march
first and what would happen is I
couldn't stop because there was no place
to pitch the tent and there was no I did
find a spot to pitch a tent finally
after two days of traveling and that we
couldn't boil any of the water though it
was round because we grabbed snow and
ice to be able to make water so we can
eat and drink but there was no there was
too much salt content in the in this the
snow's to the ice was too new or single
year ice so I couldn't boil any water so
the only water we had was from the
condensation of our breath inside our
tent so I'm basically we were inside the
tent and all iced up inside I took the
pot in the pot lid and just scraped it
cautiously to be able to get every
single drop of condensation inside the
tent and that's what we only got like a
about 12 ounces of water each we
traveled another about another half a
day before we actually found a place to
camp and we pitched camp and we started
you know drinking for like four or five
hours after that but you know the ice is
melting for sure this big huge cracks of
four years ago I witnessed temperatures
zero degrees Celsius at the North Pole
in April I mean that's just unheard of
this year in January it rained in
Spitsbergen 78 degrees north you know
and that's that hasn't happened in over
40 years so I'm just talking to the
locals and and what's really going on we
use helicopters to get dropped off we
finally got dropped off this is purely
fresh lead that's probably a day old and
you can see where the ice was still
moving a little bit and that's why you
see this sort of rubble a little bit
here but you could see the crystals
forming on the ice and that's all
solid evaporating and this is the beacon
that I was discussing and our beacons
actually are a lot more accurate than
the ones that that the Arctic buoy
program was previously using and this is
after 52 days the Norwegian guy the
Dutch guy and myself if you look at our
jackets our jackets are completely soggy
it's a very humid environment there's
supposed to be a big old down puffy
jacket I'm sure you've seen Everest
jackets and stuff like that but because
of the humidity there was no loft left
in the jackets after 52 days and you can
see it's super cold out and but this is
really what I'm proud of we pitched
three is it three of these beacons two
of them are still working today and it's
been you know seven years they were
supposed to only last about five years
and they're still delivering data so we
did snow depth measurements every out
every app for a couple hours after we
pitched our tent just a typical picture
of us crossing pulling our sleds some of
the rebel terrain really low the sun's
really low on the horizon as we're
moving across this is a great picture of
just the the crystallized salt that's on
the top and that would probably support
our weight just stop in for a drink you
need to stop in and eat and drink your
burning over 10,000 calories a day and
we're only eating about 5556 I way every
single gram and it's really a science to
be able to I got a little bit wrong on
that South Pole trip because I lost so
much weight so you got to really try to
beef up before you go on these trips
because you know you're going to lose a
bunch of weight and then of course this
is the hardest junior journey in the
world there's all kinds of polar bears
polar bears are something that are they
look really fuzzy and friendly and and
but they're actually not they're one of
the few mammals that actually hunt man
and I've had quite a few encounters I
told you a minute ago about me stopping
halfway halfway through that day and I'm
in there boiling my friend mark the
Dutch guy was out doing his morning
business I'm boiling because we want it
we're so dehydrated and we needed so
much fluids that I'm boiling for for
about three or four hours trying to just
boil enough ice so we could drink Peter
was taking a route
in the sleeping bag and I hear mark
outside screaming and yelling he's going
to kill me he's going to kill me I get
the gun ready I'm unzip the tent for me
to you there's a polar bear 12-foot tall
standing on its hind legs and Mark is
swinging the shovel to keep the distance
from him from the polar bear with his
pants down by his ankles so I'm getting
the gun ready Peter gets up gets up i'm
not really the gun guy i hand him the
gun he didn't have any gloves on and he
went and grabbed the metal barrel the
gun and rift about ten layers of skin
off his hand so he's screaming mark
screaming I'm just freaking out end up
we shoot the gun in the air and scare
the polar bear weigh but we had 19
different polar bear encounters
subsequently after that and what's
happening is polar bears are going out
on the sea ice looking for seals so you
can't camp around pressure ridges and
what's happening is the ice is melting
really quickly and they're not able to
swim all the way back sometimes hundreds
of miles and so they're drowning they
say there's about 20,000 polar bears
left I'm not sure how accurate that is
but you could see here there's actually
a little beacon World Wildlife Fund
actually spent a couple million dollars
on anesthetize acouple of these females
and males and they track them so this
was actually one that actually in the
wild but there there's a tracking device
on this one and these Cubs are probably
probably two months old I would think
and the mom they're really interesting
animals they can smell a seal from eight
miles away they can not only smell seal
but they they actually the mother will
make a cave every year and she'll keep
her cubs for two to three years the mail
actually just do a walking slumber he'll
like walk for two and a half months in
in a sleepwalk kind of phase and then
they're really hungry and then we just
happen to be in their ecosystem but
they're very cute I mean super cute but
a lot of rubble terrain not a lot of
some days there it's the sun's out
sometimes sometimes it's not I'd ice you
know hold my eyelid shut frozen shut you
know we're going up over pressure ridges
I'm trying to find the most efficient
way to go
uh you have to do some paperwork but I'm
sure if one was charging me and I had no
other up you know nothing else to do
you're not supposed to yeah but you
could see some of the rebel terrain that
we're trying to cross some of these big
huge pressure ridges this is just a
bunch of rebel terrain what I'm seeing
happening going there there's not a lot
of multi-year ice at the pole itself
anymore a lot of this multi-year ice is
being pushed down to the back and
straights in Canada and baffin and
northern northern Canada and Greenland
and I'm seeing a lot of rubble terrain
like this there so what's happening this
is multi-year ice because you can see
how thick it is that's probably anywhere
from seven to 14 years old I'm seeing a
lot of single your ice up on the pole
itself and in the main part of the
Arctic and that's sort of scary to me
because it's not real thick and it's
it's actually easier for me to get to
the pole the last couple years because
of not a lot of pressure ridges so in a
lot of more open water so and we're
using sleds to be able to cross some of
these leads I designed the sleds I
designed harness a lot of the gear I
design I got my own boot bottle and
we're hopscotching from lily pad to lily
pad to be able to get there sometimes we
jump sometimes we have to swim a lot of
the time we'll just get to open water
lead and it won't even be discussing
with your teammates you just throw on
the dry suit and you start swimming I'm
afraid of the polar bear for sure so
I'll make sure that one of them has a
gun ready you know because basically
you're in this ice rubble dislike brash
ice and you're not very mobile and those
polar bears they can run 40 miles an
hour and swim real well so you want to
make sure that you're not but you we
just jump in and swim across it's not a
big deal it's the water is actually 32
degrees of water is warmer than the air
so you got a down jacket but if you work
as a team you know you work you help
each other out and sometimes I even use
kayaks you know I've actually dragged a
kayak with me and you can see how you
the shovel as a as a paddle just to get
across and a typical camp and been to
the pole I think I've been to the North
Pole 13
arms and I've been to the South Pole ten
times I think that's probably skied to
both poles more than anybody on the
planet and then you know we get picked
up by a helicopter and go back to an Ice
Station and then take a jet back to
Spitsbergen but that's that's really all
the slides I wanted to share with you
and I hope you guys enjoyed the lecture
and I'm going to answer some questions
that hopefully you guys have some
questions and if I didn't answer any of
your questions that I was forward that
were forwarded to me I'm happy to answer
some questions questions decide what
gear you need agitate um that's a great
question the question was how do I
decide what gear to take well a lot of
the time I make mistakes too you know
and one time I designed this stove that
was a basically a five-gallon drum and
it was metal and I cut little holes out
of the bottom of and I was able to put
the stove inside and it was super
efficient and then the pot fit down
inside so it was like this double walled
pot which is a great idea Nansen had it
a hundred years ago and they don't even
make them now anymore and I don't know
why because it's super efficient but
what was happening is we're in we're in
the tent and there was no ambient heat
coming off that thing and we were
freezing inside the 10 so I was like get
rid of this thing we need we need the
heat from the stove a little bit when
the vestibule so I think sometimes as
you go through testing and stuff like
that you find some things that work and
some that don't it's still in evolution
it's not like I can go to rei or the
local sporting goods store and pick up a
lot of the gear i I'm a boot model
design I designed my sleds I designed
the harnesses I work with a lot of
companies to design gear even clothing
you know for body mapping and it's a
it's an aerobic activity that we're
doing we're actually pretty much it's
it's about controlling your perspiration
if you sweat too much it's all over
because you'll just freeze you'll all
the ice will be inside your jacket and
and you'll you know basically freeze to
death so it's about I don't even wear
that much clothing I'll wear like a
light gore-tex jacket and a shirt like
this and
sit in minus 40 because we're constantly
moving and just understanding it's not a
race either it's a huge marathon so
we're just traveling quite slow and and
you know just trying to get over and
it's a lot of energy you're burning too
like I said ten ten thousand calories
did I answer questions yeah how did you
get into this oh I don't know yes I
think it was an evolution I think I
think I wanted to go climb and ski
Antarctica and I got asked to do this
polar thing and I like the challenge and
that evolved the polar thing evolved
into more education stuff like I'm doing
now and more science work because I felt
I needed it as I have a filmmaking
background I wanted to have a beginning
a middle and an end and a purpose in
what while I'm going I think I make all
my clients raise money for charity and I
think we raised I think seven million
dollars for certain charities and that
makes me feel good you know for me to be
able to go about and trying to to
understand that and and try to do good
that raise money for kids and and other
charities LIVESTRONG or cancer or
whatever you know it gives me your
meaning to be able to do it I have a
purpose and feel good about getting us
to the pole because there's a huge
carbon footprint for that you know with
all the planes and big huge Aleutian
aircraft gonna Antarctica and
helicopters and all that kind of stuff
so I think it's been an evolution and
I'll continue to push the limits of
human endurance as as I can and week ago
I was down in Cuba trying to stand up
paddleboard from Cuba to Key West and
you know I ran into they got the weather
completely wrong when my boat the boat
support that was helping me out ended up
one of the engines broke down and they
were calling for 122 knots or I'm sorry
they're calling for eight to ten knot
winds and swells one to two feet and
they ended up having their end up being
four to six foot and 15 knot winds so
you know they got it completely wrong
and I'll go back and try it again
probably in July but that was to raise
money for my charity so
good what's your current or next project
before you ah I have an amazon project
in February also do a trip to Morocco to
go skiing taking some clients to Morocco
I have a Greenland project in March
where I'll go and take some skiers off a
boat there and most of my stuff is man
climbing where you're not using lifts or
helicopters or snowmobiles it's all sort
of self-propelled human to get you there
and then I have a couple trips to
Spitsbergen which is one of my favorite
places and I think I'd like to continue
working there dr. Fields and I want to
possibly deploy some of this 911 project
up there and try to find a a really
sensible place to be able to to be able
to ascertain data from from some of the
fjords in in Spitsbergen or Svalbard
swab art is the whole archipelago the
island that we fly into a spitsbergen
and it's amazing it's above the Arctic
it's 78 degrees north you can go all the
way up to 80 degrees north so it's as
far north as you possibly can get there
simply going through Europe remark to me
like you're trying to minimize a lot of
the risk on these chips what's the
biggest risk you've ever taken why did
you take it I think for me I know my
parameters and I think when I bring
people i can try to to get them up to
speed by pictures and video and that
gives them a visual but they also need
to train physically and be ready and I
know that I can do it because I have
prior experience and I think my biggest
fear is I need to train super hard and
be ready for it but not they don't know
their parameters and and last year I
took a guy with a spinal cord injury to
the South Pole and so I had to come up
with all these new things he can't feel
his feet so I had to do I did design
thermo couplers that I taped to his toes
and then run cables all the way up his
leg and then have like a little
temperature gauge and a stomach and I
had to look at it every every hour to
make sure that he wasn't going to freeze
his toes off so I think every new
project has new challenges and I think
that's part of it for me
you know and I want to make sure that
everybody safe you know I'm the guide
I'm the person out there pushing pushing
these people and want to make sure that
they're successful and that would be
awful if you know it's not about their
disability it's about their ability and
if something happened to them that would
be really bad on my point so you know to
try to overcome that and really be
sensible about it and try to think about
everything i mean i think that's that's
really really important and I think yeah
I'll continue to do it you know go ahead
so you doing anything expeditions have
the other says like why am I doing this
to myself like how do you think of the
normal like it's easy 20 present
difficulties it's easy to give up right
so how do you keep up the motivation
during such times I think I'm pretty
motivated individual now know that
there's a collecting science or I'm I'm
doing it raising money for charity and
that motivates me you know I know that
there's going to be good from it I'm not
just going to go to the pole and beat my
chest or get to the summit of something
I know that there's good gonna come from
it and it gives me purpose and why I do
it and I think that's really the key to
be honest with you and I you know people
say what was what's the most dangerous
trip you've ever been on you know and I
could probably say honestly it was
probably the drive down here on the 101
you know so you know it's like
everything has their point you know so
you know and I'm afraid not to live i
think you know you ascertain a lot of
knowledge in and when you go to these
extreme environments and the gear is all
there and you try to to double-check
everything and I certainly don't have a
death wish you know I'm out there you
know in really inhospitable places and
I'm humbled by it and I respect it and I
think you need to have that attitude
when you go to these places have you
don't have no food I have a couple of
times i calculated wrong and I've had
two to ration toward the end but yeah I
mean I try not to make that mistake very
often I mean but you know in its down
south it's an equation you know 10 days
into the trip even though it's a 60 day
trip you have this much food this much
fuel and you
to travel this much distance each day
and if you don't make that distance the
equation changes simple North Pole is
different I mean you could ski 20 miles
and get pushback 10 you know just in
your tent at night so that's an anomaly
I mean you can't really calculate for
that one but South Pole you know you're
moving you know you know every day it's
a very civilized structured way of life
every day you get up at 6am and get that
stove going you eat and drink and then
you pack up your stuff and you have to
start moving and 14 hours later you set
up the tent and hopefully you made your
distance and you do it again you know
it's a very routine almost to the point
where you don't want it to end you know
in a very strange way I mean once you
achieve your goal you become so focused
and so regimented that it's like oh my
gosh it's over I want to get up and ski
tomorrow kind of thing so good how do
you train I pull tires um I have attire
and put a tire behind me and I carry it
to the top of even sometimes when
the days are shorter now I'll do it with
a headlamp on eleven o'clock at night
run ski you know in the winter time I'm
actually I ski about 200 days a year so
I do a lot of back country singing I
skin up you know seven or eight thousand
feet before 9am and then go home your
muscles or cardio or just everything
that's a great question i think it's
important to simulate the same activity
that you're going to do so for me it
would be pulling that tire to simulate
me pulling the sled I do other I don't
really go to a gym or anything I do
outside stuff you know I climb my ski I
run I do some push-ups and I got a pull
up bar in my house and you know I do all
that to try to stay fit but um you know
I think mentally and physically you have
to be ready for these things and I
trained super hard because if something
happened to my client or for my friends
I know that I could pull my sled his
sled and possibly him if I needed to so
I think going into it I wouldn't want to
be on day two and say man I should have
trained more I will never ever do
so I think simulating the same activity
I've been paddling a lot all summer i
think i did I went around Lake Tahoe and
that's 77 miles in 16 hours and 33
minutes I think I paddled almost six
hours a day for probably three months so
just to get ready for Cuba you know so i
was pretty ready for that and so you
know i think you put the time in and you
can do it and then the rest of it's just
mental head to pull a climb i have had
to pull a client sled and then they
skied so and that's a little bit of
maybe you know not communicating or them
not feeling right sometimes when you're
on the Arctic Ocean I've seen this
happen a couple times where people get
swollen in really cold temperatures and
I think that was the case with this
particular person might be a thyroid
thing or or something like that but I've
seen it a couple times with clients and
that's the immuno you can't plan on that
you know sometimes that people react
differently to cold temperatures your
body is super resilient it takes me two
or three days to to adjust a really cold
temperatures same thing the heat you
know it takes me two or three days to to
adjust to heat to you know it's amazing
how resilient your body is good I think
there's a lot of publicity about the
shrinking extend of ice in the Arctic
seems like not so much publicity or
whatever about the Antarctic area you
mentioned I guess in the liddell say
that there's a lot of the Shelf moving
and collapsing them but the interior is
building up and agree with the kind of
nipped situation well Antarctica I think
I touched on it briefly and I'll go to a
little bit more but um the Antarctic is
growing I think there's water
temperatures that are changing down
south that's affecting that's from
climate change I think the early the
really alarming thing is up north and
the Arctic Ocean and I think we're going
to see grave differences and changes in
the eastern United States and Western
Europe because of where it's located I
think those are the temperatures and
even Katrina I mean is it it's something
that intensified from
the warming water you know I think what
happens with with this polar ice melt
it's really so important for our Gulf
Stream and what what she's teaching
about the albedo and the reflectivity
and these thermohaline circulation of
actually this polar ice melt and what
happens and I know that you're learning
all this but you know this salt water
that's melting and dives deep and heads
toward the equator and the warm
equatorial water is heading toward the
poles in every season that melts and so
you change that melt pattern a little
bit you're going to change the Gulf
Stream and you change weather patterns
and so on and so forth and that's that
is just a layman's that it's so it's so
much more complex than that you know and
I'm just sort of talking like I talked
to kindergarteners so so I apologize but
it's a lot more complex than that but
that's a basic introduction to it and I
know you guys are learning a lot about
that now Oh back to supplies um so do
you carry any water with you or do you
read else I live L got all on the way
you just fuel fuel and stove that's my
life support if something happened to
the stove I can fix it if I lose fuel
then it's all over well it's wait yes
why Cabot in iPad up these five gallon
things and I put in my sled or I have
metal metal fuel bottles all white gas I
use ms our stove xtk X's and they're
good on Everest absolutely how to launch
I makes me whole how much he'll write it
depends on how many days say like two
weeks two weeks all hull it's usually
about 400 milliliters per person per day
so depending on how many clients I have
or how many people I do the calculation
and you know 10 gallons maybe for two
people for two weeks able to less eight
so it when it's colder in its freezin it
takes more fuel to burn and also an
altitude at 9,000 feet when you're at
the South Pole it takes more fuel to
burn so you got to calculate all those
type of things and you always go heavy
you know fuel is the main thing that you
need you know you can live
I can ration food and stuff like that
but if I don't have water I'm gonna die
so fuel is like one of the things that
you pack in there and you want to have a
bunch of something heavy like how how
much those of like what she bear the
bare minimum do you pack I think he's
taking a you know a decade to really
fine-tune that and I've gotten pretty
good at it I mean I lay everything out
and weigh every gram all my food you
ever see those camping packages that
freeze-dried food in ID Camp those I
actually work with a company in in
boulder colorado and i add more protein
meats and stuff like that and i put in a
plastic bag and i cut it off and i
actually write down the caloric intake
and what it is and the type of foods
that are coming out or like they have
all kinds of great stuff turkey
Tetrazzini and kung pao chicken and so
that's something that i really look
forward to at the end of the day it's
one of the few things that you do you
want to make sure that you have really
good food and that you're getting enough
caloric intake and it's super important
I mean during the day you're eating nuts
and freeze dried fruit and beef jerky
and you know hopefully chocolates that
aren't too too big and you know and a
lot of nuts and that kind of thing so
during the day and then a soup maybe a
super navy some electrolyte during the
day but in breakfast is usually muesli
or a granola or oatmeal in the morning
with olive oil on it or a stick of
butter and you know it's like a high-fat
diet you want to be able to eat a lot of
fat because you're burning calories and
on the longevity part of the thing it'll
definitely take its toll so you know I I
designed you know the diet to to try to
eat close to 6,000 calories a day and
the food's all are in that little
plastic and then I can actually burn
that plastic and my trash is that big
you know and I could put you know 60
days in a sandwich bag and I'm not home
if you took those metal aluminum
packages and you had 60 days of those I
mean that's probably two kilos of just
excess weight the I didn't need to carry
so I think you think about it and you
try to minimize it as much as possible I
mean there's things that you have to
bring
you know and there is luxury items like
a book or iPad you know down south I can
use the solar panel to recharge
batteries up north the sun's too low
there's no ambient and it's actually
fairly warm inside the tent you can
actually the tent will warm up because
of where the Sun sits but up north it's
it's still brutally cold you know
because it still sits olo on the horizon
it's even very difficult to get a solar
charge so I carry a brick of battery
just in case my Sat phone gets left on
and I'm able to recharge it emergency
taking kids on trips sometimes what's
that like will be taken I've taken an
eight-year-old down to the Antarctic
Peninsula and I think it's great I've
taken a ten-year-old to the Amazon I
think what I do is I get the student
involved in a journalism in a box where
they write the script to be able to talk
to students when I do these high-speed
feeds so I'm able to have a began in a
macbook pro with a camera on it that can
go wireless and actually connect with
students in classroom we could do it
right in here you know and I could be
there and they not only are in charge of
doing the dispatch to a school each day
but they have to edit a video they have
to send pictures and do a blog each day
so students can learn from students so
it's really actually quite impactful and
sometimes I take high school kids I had
two high school kids on my last trip and
they were sort of the journalism people
and we have myself and we have marine
biologist noreth ologist and guides and
stuff like that that are helping with if
there's questions that someone says oh
that penguin that's pecking at your boot
how old is that and the kids might not
know but you can say oh well that
penguin is probably you know six weeks
old it's going to take another two weeks
for to lose all its feathers and then go
hunt for itself so you know you want to
be able to be able to articulate the
right information to the students as
well so that's a big part of it I mean I
like bringing kids with me I think kids
just don't want to open up a textbook
and learn about a penguin but if they
can see one live and be able to ask
questions I think it engages them and
wanting to learn tick
depends on the peninsula ski sale trips
or the 13 days 12 nights and they run
about 8,000 US dollars and then you
still have to get down to ash y ax the
Amazon trip is about I think four
thousand dollars and that's for 12 days
and we do some stand-up paddling and I
got lights LED lights so we go out
paddling at night and you can see all
the fish because it's the Rio Negro it's
it's not the it doesn't have the
brackish groundwater you can really see
clear there's all kinds of peacock bass
we fish we live sustainably we trade
with the indigenous tribes we stop in
indigenous tribes and and interact with
them it's it's really pretty cool trip
and I've done four of those and it's a
lot of fun and I'm going to try to do a
bunch of rain forests around the world
and my educational part is really to
talk about deforestation and
biodiversity and talk about some of the
issues that are going on because the
river is everything everybody travels by
the rivers and you know it's a physical
thing to try to paddle all the way down
but really it's more about learning and
I love learning about wildlife and
culture and all those type of things so
I continue to go different places so I
can learn too good a spot wildlife you
mentioned the polar bears being in
trouble what else do you see is you
travel around the world that's having
pressure on it especially know the
Amazon is a perfect example twenty
percent of the the Amazon rainforest has
been deforested and you know there
there's so many medicinal purposes with
the with the rainforest and and animals
that people don't even know about every
time I go down there I have scientists
on board my 24 passenger boat that are
looking for new species and then you
know it's like oh no I've never seen
this one before but this is new species
let's call it you know the Jones fish
because dr. Jones it just found it so I
mean there's a lot of that going on and
I think the Amazon is just a remarkable
place to learn and you know it's it
really inspiring to me and I want to go
to more rain forests around the world
and Cambodia Laos and do more
paddleboard trips and learn more about
some of these places so and I am seeing
allotted I mean I'm seeing
uh penguins usually go back to the same
rookery every year and I have seen a few
rookeries that actually have they
dissipated and they've gone elsewhere or
they're just not there and that's that's
rare so and also I'm seeing you know
with the less krill populations they're
postponing their trip down to Antarctica
and coming later it depends on the snow
year too if there's a lot of snow on
land that can't build nests so I'm
seeing some of that going on so that
really depends if it is a low snow year
then they're able to start earlier and
so that's being affected but I am seeing
a lot of krill the krill populations are
a lot lesson and that's reflective on
the wildlife and you know its survival
the fittest if there's not enough food
then you know something's got to go so
I'm gonna ask another women Hector are
you noticing much sick problem since
you're going you know I would imagine
snow might be getting darker yeah you
know I haven't noticed too much of that
I have had some friends in Alaska in
northern Canada that had some stuff from
China with some some of the the weather
and bringing some of the smog and stuff
like that all the way over to the upper
canada and also Alaska but to be honest
with you I haven't physically noticed
any of that it's pretty pristine and
it's knows when I'm up there I'm up
there for you know a couple weeks in
April the season super short it's only
about twenty one days and I'm on the ice
probably 18 or 19 of those days so I'm
not seeing much there I mean I'm seeing
a lot of sort of seaweed and stuff in
some of the ice but that's a natural
phenomenon that's not I mean most the
isis has been you know that's it's a
greenish type of algae that's in the ice
and that's normal but i haven't seen any
darking suit patterns or anything i will
in Spitsbergen because they actually
burn coal there and it's a hydroelectric
coal and there's stood everywhere on all
the snow
but that's uh that's a whole different
thing that's not from anyone you know
that's from the local town you see your
profession is like a realistic one for
someone your age when you first started
oh I think it's like an evolution I mean
I didn't this isn't what i said i was
going to do ten years ago I think it's
it evolved you know and I mean 12 years
ago if he ever said I beat Antarctica 24
times I'd probably say no way you know
and I think when you step out and do
something and you you're passionate
about it you know and hopefully I'll be
able to go this year again you know and
I continue I don't take it for granted i
love going back and i love doing the
science work and hopefully i'll be able
to go back every year as long as i can
because it is it's amazing place and I'm
blown away by it so I hope to be able to
continue to travel and come to the go to
these places and hopefully learn more
but you know who knows it might be three
years from now we won't be able to ski
to the North Pole and then I'll have to
come up with ways to get there like
kayak so and that's why I bring some of
these you know kayaks or floating sleds
and to be able to get there I've had to
use them almost every year or swim you
know what happens if you got a client
they paid a bunch of money to get to
this to the North Pole and i'll send us
a big lake and the North pulls away
there how we're going to get there you
got to swim there with your GPS try to
it it's 3,000 feet of water below
me you know there it's usually only a
you know a foot or a couple feet of ice
maybe just a couple inches so and the
Russians actually placed a flag down
there chillin gar off with the that was
in the Duma and they claim it because
there's a strip a land that goes all the
way into Russia so they think that
that's part of their part of their land
they claim the North Pole 3,000 feet
down and in a super sub so
the number of climbers like in the
Himalayas and on average do you see that
same phenomenon at the poles and any
impact to be honest with you it's such a
new thing there's probably been less
than 500 people that whiskey to the pole
there's been over 5,000 a bit on Everest
am I taking advantage of that taking
people and using it as a tourist thing
absolutely i'm one of nine international
polar guide association which is a
making sure that we travel safely in
these environments and you know that
that just started it like six months ago
you know we all have the right criteria
and skill and use the right gear to be
able to take people safely and that's
just starting sort of like how they're
in the mountains they have a guide
system UI a GM or mga is the American
guide Association so now we were trying
to grasp that so we can actually take
people there and visit there safely so
yes am i part of the problem taking
people there I mean I want to peep I
want people to be ambassadors for
Antarctica and for the Arctic Ocean so
we can change it and keep it pristine
and clean and and and for many years to
come it's not it's I don't think it's
going to go away in our lifetime but our
kids and our kids kids you know they
might have more of an issue with it you
know and I don't know you know it's it's
look at the graph you know twenty
percent already and you know three years
ago I might not be able to ski to the
pole so your carbon footprint and take
John Doe like packing everything out
visitation see that with other yeah no
worries on the same page all my clients
are on the same you know we're all
everybody here I'm sure is I mean we all
recycle we all trying to travel in on
bikes and you know rescind duo do the
right thing I don't know I don't have
any friends that you know you go to
foreign countries in there throwing
stuff out the window you know that
didn't that just wouldn't happen here
and probably still does I mean I just
walk on the side of the road there's all
kinds of stuff it's probably out of
somebody pickup truck that blown out or
whatever but I think everybody is
conscious about it and we all want to
preserve and protect this planet
which we live and and I think that's
through education so what's her what
would be your message to these guys what
can they do for this undated I think we
touched on that right now you know is
continue to protect this planet which we
live it's an amazing place and you know
it's it's it's not getting any better
and I think we all need to do something
about it and and anything that we do I
think is helpful and can we reverse the
our carbon footprint absolutely can we
change this you know can we stop the ice
melt from from the Arctic which i think
is an early warning sign I think we can
try you know and I think you're trying
to do some great things to maintain that
and be able to do that it's accelerating
an alarming rate in some places like
Greenland I mean there's chunks of ice
that are just being you know miles and
miles of ice just being just gone
overnight because of some of this these
aight melt ice melts and the Mulan's and
stuff like that i mean it's it's crazy
and what what I'm seeing in just the
short period of time that I've been
doing it I've only been doing it for 11
years up there so I'm seeing big
differences so you know it's just
continue to collect out and see if we
can find a solution is really the idea
and I think you're doing the right
things for it engineering but hopefully
you learned a little bit about the
Arctic in the Antarctic and uh thank you
guys very much for having me and thank
you and thanks for coming Satish and
students and Marco and for coming for
launching Mike and Chelsea for coming to
you